with peter has been some of the most fun
i've had
as well as working with several other
folks in this room i'll highlight some
of that shortly so
i am going to do
um
a talk that is
as opposed to being focused on results
and where things went well
it will be focused on
interesting problems where stuff didn't
work
my goal is to set up
the subsequent
discussion at least a little bit
however my computer has decided not to
go into presentation mode
so we'll see how this goes there we go
something
um
so my group we
work at the intersection of statistics
and biology environmental science and we
try to find really challenging problems
that uh
force the development of some of some
new approaches and then we collaborate
with very talented groups of statistics
and computer science to deliver new
solutions but not to microsoft products
at all
okay
let's try that one more time
maybe or just blackness i just wing this
it's fine um
[Laughter]
i got nothing
oh there we go now it's
okay
sorry folks this is not what we need uh
i am i'm mentally cutting slides we'll
stay on time i promise
um
congrats i got nothing
yeah it's powerpoint yeah do you wanna
let's do these two things in parallel
and we'll see which one works first
still got spinning wheel of death
yep now it's
oh we've got a white screen with a
spinning ball
all right
back amongst yourselves folks
okay can i email this to an address
the email address in there
you can try from that
you're now thinks it's
nope
oh my god is it going to work
nope it's not going to work
cinnamon
maybe
maybe
it doesn't look like it's working on my
end
no worries i'm gonna i'm gonna be quick
it might actually be working keep doing
that but i'm gonna pretend like this is
gonna work
okay
so we're now gonna get a very quick talk
uh uh and i'm gonna start out just by
framing the class of problems that i'm
going to address we're going to be
talking about problems we have to do
pattern discovery as opposed to pattern
recognition the the difference being in
pattern recognition you know what you're
looking for and so it the problem
reduces to simple prediction right
you're fitting some deep net to
recognize pictures of cats and pictures
of cats whatever
uh and in pattern discovery you're
generally doing something more
complicated here's an example from
functional genomics we've heard a lot
today where you where you have a whole
bunch of transcriptomics data or gene
expression data and you want to find
networks of genes
sub-networks of genes that are
responsible for driving uh subnetworks
of metabolites or metabolism
right and that that is not a pattern
recognition process pattern discovery
problem because you've got no idea what
these subnetworks are or what these
metabolites are a priori this is a
pattern you have to discover right so
that's that's the general class of
problems of interest
now
broadly for problems of this type
what we're looking at is we have some
sort of data and some sort of prior
knowledge and what we're trying to get
to is mechanism we're trying to
understand a mechanism how the system
works
what we have in between the data and
prior knowledge and the discovery of
that mechanism is some sort of learning
architecture and that could be a
statistical model could be a glm it
could be a neural network it could be
random force whatever but the key point
is that we are learning that we are
using it to try to get to mechanism
now depending on how much data we have
the number of samples as well as how
complex that data is
we have access to very different classes
of models to try and solve a problem
like this if we have very little data
we're going to be doing very classical
stuff uh if we have more data we might
be doing piecewise models mars howe
things like that to name some local
favorites if we have a little more we do
ensemble methods random forests things
like that and then more and the models
get increasingly complex and ditto for
the overall complexity of data whether
we're trying to solve some simple
multi-regression problem or if we have
many many different modes of data we're
trying to interrelate
and there are
driving data sets
in the biological sciences at every
level of complexity here from trying to
understand climate science to synthetic
biology all the way down to clinical
biology right phase one human trials
will always be small data in a phase one
trial you're asking the question hey if
i actually give a person this drug will
they die
that will always be a small numbers game
right so so biology drives not just one
set of these methods but the entire
hierarchy of them
and in that setting we are going from
data sources through some learning
machine to
some representation of what that machine
has learned some object on which we can
do something very like inference okay
and now i'll give some real examples of
what this looks like and the hope is
that these these uh
extracted representations the machine
has learned are sufficiently realistic
and sufficiently reflect mechanism that
we can do things like design future
control systems etc
uh now one of my favorite projects that
we've done in this area is we've been
you who's here who'll be talking on the
panel in a minute uh as well as uh
samantha basu at the time he's a joint
postdoc now he's gone on to
um now he's gone on to cornell
uh and iterative random forest was a way
of doing
uh sort of inference with random forest
but trying to find features that
interact uh together now everything that
a forest knows is encoded in paths from
root to leaf in individual trees right
and the idea behind it or the random
forest was a very simple one
it was extract the information extract
the sequence of features that are used
in individual trees run them through
random intersection trees and then
identify groups of features
that co-occur most frequently okay so
very simple idea but it yields really
nice insights because you can identify
interacting subsets of features i mean
non-linear structure regardless of how
many features are in them right so of
any form or order
all right now
the way this works in practice after
you've extracted that information and
this is the fast fast version i
apologize and this question is curious
you're curious after you've extracted
that information
you can go back to the trees and ask
questions also about the decision rules
that were actually learned and if you
extract the decision rules along with
the features you can start to draw
things like response surfaces
right and so this method was developed
originally to handle genomics data and
to answer questions about gene
expression and gene control
but since then we've applied to lots of
different stuff and i'm going to give a
different example now but this is the
kind of information you can extract
right so a pair of interacting features
as well as the actual function that the
forest has learned because that function
is encoded precisely in the splits you
extract all the splits you ensemblize
across them you get a response surface
for binary classification on the z axis
you just have probability and on the x
and y axis you have the range of the
support
the domain of the support
okay so here is
one of my
favorite problems in which we've applied
this method uh so this is trying to
learn the controls of an environmental
system in this case the environmental
system in question is an agronomic
system it's it's uh corn and soy
cultivation right so something outside
biomedical science uh still bio in this
setting we gather many many layers of
data hundreds of layers of data that
describe the relationship between a
plant and its environment and the idea
is can you learn to
control it can you learn to drive toward
favorable outcomes
so you fit a random forest model you
identify what are the important features
and then you extract something that
looks like this and this plot shows a
relationship between
potassium and phosphorus and it shows a
sweet spot that is dependent nonlinearly
on both features
and the first time i showed this was at
a usda conference
and i was booed and as many of you know
it's not easy to get booed at an
academic conference but i did it i did
it
and it's because this is in a complete
contrast to the previous 50 years of
agronomics that treats uh individual
features especially things like
potassium and phosphorus as independent
uh but it's not this has been validated
now by third parties exactly how it
works but people hadn't treated it uh as
a data science and control problem and
random forest brought the light very
nicely these sorts of nonlinear
dependencies everywhere
i had a very clever grad student or
still have actually he's graduating now
this semester
come on
carl
there we go
carl had a very clever idea that we take
these individual response surfaces that
a random forest has learned and do
something like forward backward
regression and then just build a
generalized additive model out of the
response surfaces that were extracted
from the forest okay so this goes from
this data prior knowledge to mechanism
right now we're hoping that those
individual response surfaces actually
correspond to relevant controls for the
system so in the potassium and
phosphorus example it's not enough to
control those two things independently
in fact they're a single control you
have to use both of them simultaneously
and carl found that if you just wrapped
a generalized additive model around
these response surfaces you had about as
much predictive power as the random
force from which they were derived and
most importantly accuracy up to about
experimental error in most of the ways
we tried it
and now for the last three years we've
been using that to drive fertilizer
application on a thousand acre research
farm in arkansas
and we are now putting about twenty
dollars per acre back in the farmer's
pocket and that's more than thirty
percent gain on their total operation
it's a hugely material gain and it's
precisely from the insights derived from
this random forest model applied in this
setting
now
that's cool okay so where did things
start to go off the rails
uh
so
there is tremendous
mechanistic heterogeneity and i just
showed you an additive model that
treated things as very homogeneous
this is data from a real clinical trial
i think this one was done by bayer sorry
field trial then by bayer
and on the y-axis we have yield and
bushels per acre this is delta from
control regions and then on the x-axis
are just individual fields ordered from
worst to best in terms of the impact of
the of the application and some fields
were down minus 20 bushels per acre so
substantial detriment and some fields
were up 40 hugely beneficial what you
wish you knew of course before buying
this product is which fields were going
to be garbage and which fields were
going to be great and then you could put
it in just the right places so how do
you do that
so
uh we took again an iterative random
forest approach to try and learn
controls for this setting
except now
instead of just doing random
intersection trees on the features that
the forest was using
we did it on the observations that live
in the leaf nodes
and so now you have a more complex type
of object you have an object that
associates
interactions or local models with
particular subsets of observations
and that creates depending on where you
slice it a partition on a field site so
this is 8 000 acres thusly partitioned
to the reasonably felicitous cutoff
and what you get now are local models
with actually completely distinct
support so you learn that there are
different drivers that are principal
drivers of productivity in this region
this green region compared to this blue
region compared to this pink region and
you can actually control decisions
like okay this is real data
uh you know this amendment here is going
to be very beneficial that amendment's
going to be harmful and then it actually
flips over here
right and we can go further and figure
out why this is and it turns out because
this tends to be very high moisture this
tends to be very dry
and that is actually a drought treatment
doesn't matter but that actually works
right you can gain insight into how the
local model
functions so that suggests
uh a particular
way
of thinking about the types of models
that are being learned now peter had a
paper is one of my favorite papers of
his
uh which is a local polynomial
regression on unknown manifolds uh this
paper they showed
that the scaling how much data you need
to do polynomial regression is just
awful you know it's really rough uh and
the fascinating corollary of that is
that if you're able to do regression in
really high dimension there has to be
some kind of low dimensional structure
or you'd never be able to do it with
finite data
right that's a tremendously conceptually
useful result
now for the types of systems we study we
know
that hundreds of thousands of features
are very important to keep around yet
not locally
when we go that local step to dive down
to figure out what are the controls
locally in this case in a very literal
sense of in space but when we dive down
locally things are much much simpler so
if i can look at the random force or
whatever type of learning machine and
say something about where individual
observations in this case may be regions
of a field in another case maybe
patients where individual observations
are embedded what's near what's far and
then i can ask for a collection of
patients or a collection of field sites
what does the local model look like and
this is precisely the picture of the
field that i showed you
now and this is
you know sort of where we would like to
go
to be able to go from some global model
that does an exquisitely good job of
prediction to understanding the local
structure and the local controls and
this turns out to be reasonably feasible
uh for random forest models uh but how
would you do this for a deep nat how
would you do this in a reinforcement
learning framework
right these are that is
you know
incredibly open incredibly open research
uh but i think in an enormously
important direction to answer this
question are there these sorts of local
structures local regression local
whatever
that you can extract and then gain
scientifically meaningful insight
okay
another example where we have
fascinating heterogeneity this story is
meant mostly uh to entertain
now
sars cove to infection fatality rates
that's a map across the u.s
circa january 2020 something like that
is incredibly heterogeneous right
infection fatality rates in new york and
boston were much much much much higher
than virtually anywhere else in the
country
there were other regions particularly in
the southeast where you had little
pockets of extremely high
mortality and then there were regions
where there was very very little and you
might ask what drives that why is it so
heterogeneous can you figure out what
the drivers are the process drivers of
infection fatality rate heterogeneity
so
uh
you know we took a data set uh which was
which allowed us to estimate ifr
infection fatality rate i won't go to
the details but
basically we grabbed counties after
their infection fatality had after
they'd had enough deaths for some
definition of enough and then we looked
at their trajectory over time
uh
now i have a research scientist my group
josh ladau who is absolutely brilliant
and he came up with a theory that a
driver of infection fatality rate
heterogeneity may be the environmental
microbiome specifically the household
microbiome when he told me this i said
josh is the stupidest thing i ever heard
but he was he was very convincing and he
found some money for it so he did it
uh there was previously this thing
called the thousand home study where
they sampled about 1100 homes in just
about 500 u.s counties
and they did a sequencing method to
figure out what was there in terms of
fungi bacteria that sort of thing
uh and now
uh and you could define uh derivatives
of that
like the breaker this beta diversity
which will become important in a moment
grey curtis beta diversity just tells
you how similar the indoor environment
is to the outdoor environment because we
got match samples we got one sample in
your living room we got one sample on
your patio
uh okay now there is an old
immunological hypothesis called the old
friends hypothesis
and the old friends hypothesis states
that it was really important to play
around and get covered in the microbes
with which our species evolved okay
uh
and you know so particular microbes and
now
josh formulated this hypothesis it's
entirely his so indoor outdoor beta
diversity on the x-axis covered 19
severity rate on the y
if if the indoor was very much like the
outdoor so breaker is beta diversity low
if the indoor is just like the outdoor
then the upper quantiles of
the severity distribution be very
compressed people won't die
okay if beta diversity is very high
meaning indoors very very different than
the outdoor
it could be anything and the reason it
could be anything instead of just high
the reason that's just hypothesis
because lots of other factors right
socioeconomic demographic lots of other
factors but this was his no this was his
hypothesis of course the null hypothesis
just that it's unstructured
all right
now here's what the actual data looks
like uh you're going to focus on fungal
beta diversity for reasons that an
immunologist would be happy to explain
um but this is this is the real data so
this is bray curtis beta diversity on
the x-axis this is coven-19 uh mortality
rate this is sort of heat mappy thing
and each of these lines is just simple
linear regression fit for the quantiles
right so it's going quantile by quantile
90th quantile 75th 50th 25th all
positive slopes 75th and 90th really
positive slopes
now you ask okay
interesting is it significant
the answer is yes i won't go into the
details but uh if you look at the
infection fatality rate um percentile
and then you look at the slope of uh of
the regression line against beta
diversity
as a function of percentile
it's hugely significant and the effect
size is actually massive the effect size
is on par with the median of the
mortality distribution
uh in fact
the effect size is so strong
that uh we compiled the data set about
745 socioeconomic and environmental
factors that influence covalent 19. the
only ones that are actually stronger
than uh the fungal this fungal
microbiome measure this breaker to spata
diversity our percent population over
the age of 85 and a couple variations of
that uh percent population high density
housing percent population in residence
over 10 years uh mean household income
mean soil moisture levels and then
there's a few others just variations of
this different breakdowns by ethnicity
and things like that but that's that's
it right from the the fun the effective
fungal is nearly as strong as as as
those things that are very very
obviously very important
and in fact you can identify just a few
fungal genera that appear to drive this
pattern the strongest genera exhibit
exquisite patterns here on the x-axis
for both these plots is indoor relative
abundance this is outdoor relative or
sorry vice versa outdoor relative
abundance indoor relative abundance both
these plots are reasonably diagonal
meaning that things happen when they are
similar i.e when the breaker does beta
diversity is close to zero
and the color chart here is mortality
suppression how many infect it's
infections divided by deaths how
suppressive is the presence of this
microbe
and for these microbes the effect sizes
are very significant very very
significant if you have a good amount of
this outside and you have a good amount
of this inside yeah
you're going to have you know
considerably less death in your county
what's also very remarkable is that this
pattern and everything i just said it
only holds in counties where residents
have been there for 10 plus years right
so this is a heat map of the u.s human
population stability county by county
or at least the 500 counties for which
we have data
and then we have existing residents per
new resident
so
incoming residents per new sorry
existing residents are already there for
new incoming residents uh between 2010
and 2017. why those years the years we
found data for
uh and it goes from 4.3 to 250 with a
median of 14.
if you threshold at the median
so these are high turnover counties and
these are low turnover counties
all of the predictive power
all of our capacity to predict as a
function of breakers beta diversity
concentrates in the counties with low
population turnover and from that you
can do nice things like make a risk map
of the us
uh where size of the dot is proportional
to mortality suppression it's also
there's a nice story about soil ph that
goes along with this and why this might
be functionally true but
that's that's cool so now
that's all nice but the entire story i
just told you was dependent on a
brilliant bit of intuition by a very
very clever uh
computational uh ecologist
could you have got that from the data
alone
right you would hope that you could
recover that just through a machine
learning process
right so can you rediscover the old
french hypothesis from data along so we
tried irf we tried quantile regression
for us we tried distributional random
force we tried a few other things too
that weren't actually random for us
but all the results were very similar we
could recover the really strong main
effects like this these are super
obvious
but we couldn't recover any higher order
interactions and nothing was
particularly stable so this is in the
regression problem we have 745
predictors and then the the outcome of
infection fatality rate so the
hypothesis is that we have too few
independent observations of the upper
quantiles for any of these methods
to uh to
to nail this problem for us and i'd be
really interested peter to discuss yeah
the distributional very interested to
discuss that with you show you the
results um but it it illustrates that
these methods are still fairly data
hungry right 500 data points not nothing
can't still can't resolve it
okay one last story that i'm going to
very very very fast
so here
was a project that instead of small data
being a problem we had essentially
infinite amounts of data because we had
access to a simulation
uh so we were trying to design small
molecules to disrupt cysco2 proteins
okay
for some reason department energy
decided it wanted to compete with pharma
why it did that i have no idea but they
gave us much money to do it so we did
now this is in collaboration with dan
jacobson's group at oak ridge national
laboratory
and uh marty heads group couple others
uh in in this in this setting
we have a target protein and this
protein has some binding site that if we
could disrupt it we would prevent the
function of the protein and we're trying
to design small molecules that fit in
that binding pocket very very tightly
and constitute essentially suicide
inhibitors of the protein we have a
simulation that's okay to say whether or
not that a small molecule will satisfy
that
we built out a reinforcement learning
approach very clever student of mine
eulen wu
who's a grad student here at berkeley
got it into iclr's very nice job uh a
few clever bits but i'm going to skip
over in the interest of time
the point is that he built a really nice
deep learning model that outperformed
everything else including maldiq and
from google actually pretty handily
these are these are pretty big
differences in terms of delta g for the
energy calculation
but then this is the important plot this
unlabeled thing i don't know if you can
see the colors but it goes from light to
dark and it's unlabeled because it
doesn't matter what the labels are we
tried labeling this number of carbon
rings we tried laboring it by other
molecular features the latent space for
this wonderful network that performs so
beautifully
is totally uninterpretable hideously so
like if you squint and zoom way in you
can convince yourself that there's sort
of some local structure and things
partition out locally but there's
absolutely nothing obvious from this so
we fit a method that could design
molecules but what do we learn from it
design principles for molecules
certainly not
we learned virtually nothing from this
exercise
right what have we learned from alpha
fold
where the new soft matter physics where
the new design principles for proteins
nada freaking nothing
how do we use these incredibly
predictive methods
to do science to gain insight
that's that's the huge open problem so
in this trajectory from data and prior
knowledge through to mechanism there are
still some really big holes
like we've heard some amazing talks on
some of these components down here today
and and these are amazing and they're
working so well
the methods up here
are working better but they're still
very data hungry
and then methods up here there is
nothing the saliency maps for reasons uh
giles hooker could tell us at great
length um are just garbage and then uh
lime challenging too so this is this is
the problem i think right how do how do
we do inference in in these settings
okay i'm going to shut up thank you very
much
okay let's take two questions
um
let me rephrase that can you show that
the effect of the fungal microbiome is
uh
not dependent on the local the age of
the population
anybody can yeah yeah you can target
maximum likelihood random for us
okay another question
can you say a bit with deep learning
while they're used to actually we have
some interpretation answer you hope you
will try okay we're excited about that
so it's uh it's a graph policy network
um
the the innovations for this a lot of it
is pretty similar to multi qn and stuff
that was done before the the innovations
are less in the reinforcement learning
side and more on the the science side uh
so in most of the folks who've tried to
do this molecular design stuff do it
atom by atom that's how they phrase the
the you know markov decision process
atom by adam uh instead of that we took
a library of synthetically accessible
fragments and actual chemical reactions
that human humans know how to do about
four billion of them and we use that as
the uh as the input so we explored a
design space where molecules were always
real and we always had a path to
constructing them
um and then we had a slightly clever way
of uh uh doing really curiosity driven
exploration but other than that it's
just a deep graph net convolutional
graph net uh optimized by proximal
policy optimization
i'd love to talk to you again about how
to uh
uh
how to gain some insight
and maybe you know presumably there's
something certain certainly for uh
something as exquisitely predictive as
uh alpha fold there's something to be
learned if we but knew how to query
features
um the the the input
the input are um
a discrete molecule a graph right so it
takes it to graph and then every graph
can be associated with a measure of
quality and that measure quality can be
computed by simulation
so the the reinforcement where every
time the reinforcement learning uh
algorithm wants another data point on
which to train they can just call it and
ask for it
thank you very much okay let's take our
cigarette
back for coffee let's come back it's
restarted